cold if um
cause i under i feel your pain not to
this extent with my own mom but if you
can support her more to find a man shut
the [ __ ] up big ed and colt's face off
and drop some serious f-bombs during the
90-day the single life tell-all special
you want to tell her
i moved out we're separated it all went
down after colt revealed that he and
vanessa have called it quits she's
having to live with us for three weeks
citing colt's relationship with his mom
debbie whom they lived with for getting
in the way of their marriage i'm upset
that you just can't do anything by
yourself i'm the first person first call
the first everything with you none
anymore i just feel very smothered
because you're constantly in colt's face
if i need him you're in his face it's
nonstop hey cole hey cole even if our
door is closed at the room hey cole hey
cole it's nonstop
debbie mother knows best what do you
think colt's been doing wrong in
relationships like he said he jumps too
fast and too hard uh he takes after me
in that respect i used to do the same
thing
fast and hard but vanessa and colt
aren't the only ones whose love life is
struggling debbie attempted to find love
again on the recent season of 90 day
you're just a plain jane that is not a
comrade
and even went on a few rocky dates with
cameras rolling i have cats
want to see mine
this is cookie
she's quite beautiful no that's okay i
don't need to see you and when big ed
chimed in and asked if colts could
support debbie in finding a man of her
own well all hell broke loose i feel
your pain not to this extent with my own
mom but if you can support her more to
find a man shut the [ __ ] up support i'm
36 years old okay my entire life has
been support hey colt do this
yeah colt he wasn't feeling that i don't
need to calm down
calm down polar bear calm down
okay shut the [ __ ] up you fake piece of
[ __ ]
so that's a hard no as for vanessa and
colt the show documented the two getting
engaged back in may 2021
want to get married we're engaged we're
engaged
engaged beautiful ring
and a few weeks later the pair revealed
they had already tied the knot without
telling anyone including debbie was
debbie there that was not every day
i didn't tell mom you know i love
vanessa you know she's a part of my life
she's my best friend eti was with colt
and his mom just shortly before all that
went down and he got candid about his
relationship with vanessa
vanessa for i don't know what it is
about her but we've connected in the
past years we've come in and out of each
other's lives but we just seem to always
find each other again
and at the time debbie said vanessa had
her seal of approval i think they're
really good for each other they're
really good friends they get along
terrific they
they just need to take their own time
and work it out and
build a trust
so what are the chances of vanessa and
colts getting back together
will you move back in
if debbie is not in the house
yeah